radiation on Mars is a significant
problem both solar radiation and cosmic
rays are both a problem we don't have a
dense atmosphere on Mars it's only about
1/100 the density of the atmosphere on
earth and therefore they're not a lot of
particles in the air for solar rays
coming from the Sun to collide with and
be deflected as there are on earth Mars
also doesn't have a fan Allen belt like
we have which deflects a lot of solar
radiation and it does not have a molten
core like we have which creates a
magnetosphere around the earth which
also deflects a great deal of radiation
so Mars is a very radiated place in many
ways and people will need very very
thick walls on their buildings if they
build above the surface to stop solar
radiation and to hinder most of the
cosmic rays cosmic rays are of
mysterious origin we don't actually know
where they come from but they are little
bits of atoms that are traveling at high
speed and these particles can penetrate
10 feet of steel we are exposed to them
on earth pilots who fly transcontinental
airline routes are actually exposed to
quite a bit of cosmic radiation cosmic
radiation all radiation undoubtedly in
the long run causes cancer in human
beings one of the trade-offs that you
might say of going to Mars is that you
are going to get more radiation than you
get on earth both on the trip out there
and when you get to Mars one of the
defenses we will have against radiation
on Mars is a spacesuit but on Mars we're
not going to wear spacesuits that look
like these things in the movie gravity
that are kind of like deep sea diving
bags and this huge bubble on top of your
head and they're incredibly awkward and
difficult to move around and you're kind
of encapsulated a woman and MIT who's
actually been nominated to be in the
number two person at NASA a woman named
Dava Newman
has developed a spacesuit that looks
more like something you would wear as an
exercise clothing in a gym it's very
tight-fitting kind of spandex II like it
has metallic threads in it and it's
fabulous at protecting you from
radiation at least in a short period of
time it also does another interesting
thing which is because the atmosphere on
Mars is so thin you would not explode
and you would not have nitrogen narcosis
like you do with the bends but you can't
survive long on Mars because just
walking outside if we forget about the
radiation problem
because there's not enough pressure on
your skin on earth we have 15 pounds
14.7 pounds of atmosphere piled up above
us that presses on our skin at all times
and as human beings over a long period
of time we have evolved in our bodies to
be pushing back so underneath our skin
essentially our bodies are pushing out
at all times to compensate for that 15
pounds of atmospheric pressure now you
don't need 15 pounds of atmospheric
pressure pushing on you to kind of keep
you from turning into a balloon but you
do need about five or six pounds and a
sort of spandex II kind of spacesuit
will create enough pressure against your
skin so that that problem is solved so
we have to do everything we can to
protect people from radiation on Mars
and that probably means initially living
underground eventually we will live
above ground it's not that dissimilar
from Antarctica
you can't go outdoors in Antarctica in
the winter but people survive just fine
in Antarctica there's but radiation is
is a big Bugaboo